MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to "Data Vis Dev Talk."
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
In this video
series, we will talk
about Google's next-generation
business intelligence
and dashboarding
tool, Data Studio.
We will also show how you
can build your own connector
to connect to any data source
and then visualize that data.
Data Studio is a simple-to-use
yet powerful reporting tool
that can be used for free.
It is completely web-based,
so users can create and view
beautiful dashboards using
their browser regardless of what
operating system they're on.
The dynamic and interactive
nature of Data Studio
ensures that users are
always getting the updated
information when visualizing and
interactively exploring data.
Developers also get a lot of
flexibility building solutions
around Data Studio
since it works well
with other Google Cloud Platform
and Google Marketing Platform
tools.
In this video, we
will briefly talk
about how Data Studio works
and who can benefit from it.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's think of a few use cases
for data visualization first.
Maybe you are a developer
who have an existing
product or service and are
looking to build a developer
solution on top of it.
You plan to make this solution
available to all your users
in a cost-effective way.
Or maybe you're an analyst
at an organization trying
to monitor internal KPIs like
sales, or inventory data,
or have your own
balance scorecard.
As an executive, you
might need an easy to use
yet visually pleasing tool
to talk about last quarter's
growth in an all-hands meeting.
Data storytelling helps
people to understand insights
from a data set.
Journalists need tools to
make the technical parts easy
and let them focus on the
insights and storytelling
parts.
As a researcher, you
might need a platform
to visually analyze
your research data
and then publish the findings
in an interactive blog.
Or maybe you are the
owner of a unique data set
and would like to
visualize and share
that data set with others.
In each of these
use cases, it helps
to have a solution that
is, one, scalable--
it works even if a large
number of people are using it--
two, interactive-- it's not just
a screenshot or static content.
Users should be able to
tweak, adjust, change
settings and filters to
derive their own conclusions--
three, cost-effective-- it
should not break the bank
or take up massive amounts of
time for developers to build
and maintain the solution--
and four, high-performing--
the solution
should work fast and respond
quickly to user interactions
even with gigabytes of data.
Data Studio can help
you to build solutions
with all four criteria.
Data Studio makes
life easier for users,
enabling them to organize,
access, and understand
their world of information.
So let's see how
Data Studio works.
There are four steps to it--
connect, analyze,
visualize, and share.
First, you connect your
data in Data Studio.
Your data can be in
different places.
Data Studio provides
different connectors
to let you connect to your data.
We'll talk more about this
connect step in our next video.
Next comes the analyze
and visualize part.
I like to combine these
two steps, since they
are highly related and
depend on each other.
Data Studio provides different
features for these two steps.
You can use Data Studio Explorer
to visually explore the data.
Data Blending lets you blend
data from multiple sources
into one single
data source based
on a single field
or a composite key.
You can always do
manual calculations
and create custom fields
using different functions.
When it comes to
visualizations, Data Studio
comes with a number of
built-in chart types,
including bar, column,
line, time series, scatter,
et cetera.
You can also have data tables,
pivot tables, and scorecards.
There are custom templates
available in the report gallery
that can get you
started quickly.
Also, if you have need for a
specific type of visualization
and it is not available, you can
develop your own visualization
using JavaScript
libraries like D3.
Once you have built and
started using your dashboard,
you can share it with others.
Sharing works using the
Google Drive permissions.
You can provide view are edit
access to certain people using
their emails or email groups.
You can always
share using a link.
If you share edit
access with others,
multiple people can
work collaboratively
on the same dashboard,
just like Google Docs.
You can take your
dashboard link and embed it
in your website or blog post
using IFrames or oEmbed.
Viewers of your site will
be able to see the updated
data on the dashboard and
interact it on your site.
You can also use your
dashboard as a slide deck
when presenting insights
and findings to an audience.
So that was an overview
of how Data Studio works
and who can benefit from it.
In our next video,
we'll talk about how
you can connect to your
own data in Data Studio.
You can always go to
our developer site
at
developers.google.com/datastudio
for more information.
Thanks for watching.